[Music]
hello everyone
uh in the previous part of the lecture
uh i had mentioned that
under the conditions of isotropic
material behavior
we have this immense reduction from the
21 independent components of the
elasticity
tensor to the two independent components
now let's see how we can uh
have this kind of relationship coming up
in a systematic fashion
from the fourth order tensor okay so for
this we are going to use
uh a result from tensor algebra
so isotropic behavior
okay or isotropin
so the result from tensor algebra is
this
that any general fourth order isotropic
tensor
can be expressed in terms of chronic
deltas
in this fashion okay so c i j
k l is equal to so if c i j k l
is a fourth order uh
isotropic tensor then it can be
expressed as
alpha delta i j delta k
l plus beta
delta i k
delta j l plus gamma
delta let me write that
properly delta il delta
j k where alpha beta and gamma
they are constants okay so this is the
general
result from tensor uh algebra
now we are not going to go into proof of
this
rather what uh what you can do or what
you will do
is in the in the problem sheet of this
chapter
uh you will be asked to verify this
result
not prove this but verified that this is
indeed isotropic
so much in the same way that you did i
think problem number
six in the mathematical preliminaries
okay so
that will give you a better feel of what
this is all about
now in terms of making the connection
from the fourth order density to the
isotropic tensor
what we'll do is uh first thing you note
that we have
mentioned previously that there are only
two uh
constants two independent constants but
here you are seeing that
from tensor algebra is telling us uh
that
there are three independent constants so
what is going on here
so let's see that although it is written
as three
but indeed there are actually only two
of them
okay so what do we do for that
uh the first step is uh
that we interchange the ing
okay so
we interchange i and j
so what we have is the
ji is equal to
alpha delta j i
delta k l plus beta
delta j k delta il
because we have to replace the i by the
g wherever it appears
and the j by the i wherever it appears
delta j l delta i k
all right now uh
we want to subtract these two things
these two equations
okay so let's call this as uh maybe
star one and start
two we want to do star one minus star
two
you please note that on the left hand
side of star 1 i have
c i j k l on the left hand side of star
2 i have c j i k
but c i j k l is equal to c g i k l from
the minor symmetries
okay so what we'll have on the left hand
side is
0 and here
you please note that delta i j is very
much equal to delta j
i okay so these two terms also cancel
what we have left is beta
ah now you know that this is delta i k
this is delta j
this is delta i k this is delta j so
effectively what we can do is we can
take this common
with the gamma so beta minus gamma
delta i k delta
j l and here also you note
that this delta i l is present here also
delta n
together with delta j k which is also
present here okay
so we can write this as plus
gamma minus beta delta
il delta jk
now this equation that we have just
obtained
it must be true irrespective of our
choice
of the indices now
please note the significance of this
statement suppose you were to
choose i equal to 1 k equal to
let's say let's say 3
j equal to 2 and l equal to 4
okay so this term would be 0 now i is 1
l is 4 this also becomes 0 okay
so this is identically satisfied so no
particular or fresh information is
provided to us
if we make that choice we can keep on
making these choices
okay but and
in most of them you will see that you
end up with 0 equal to 0 so no problem
no problem but no no usefulness also
but suppose we were to take something
like this
that i equal to 1 a equal to 1
and j equal to 2
l equal to
2 so let's try this suppose we take i
equal to 1
equal to 1 j equal to
um well let's take uh
equal to 2 and l equal to 2
so here also we should be doing the same
thing so i equal to 1
l equal to 2 and we don't even have to
worry about the rest of it
because whenever the two indices of the
chronicle delta are not equal
this is the entire thing is going to be
zero okay but anyway just let's write
write this down j is 2 and k is 1 so
this also is 0 okay so overall this just
goes away but this one
you note it remains and very importantly
it must be true uh this relation must be
true
as we have said irrespective of our
choice of the indices
and if that is so then the only
conclusion that we can draw from here
is that beta must be equal to gamma
okay in a similar fashion uh
if we go back to this first relation and
then
maybe we interchange
the j and l will also end up with again
this kind of a
relationship that beta is equal to gamma
so overall
as i had mentioned earlier what is
indeed happening
is that uh although these are these were
appearing as
three independent constants alpha beta
gamma but in reality
as you have seen that beta is equal to
gamma so indeed
there are two independent constants uh
as i had mentioned in the
uh in the previous lecture so let's
write this down
in using just two constants in the next
page
so c i j k l
is equal to if we take a look at the
previous page
this is alpha delta i j delta kl
alpha delta
alpha delta ij delta kl
plus beta we take
it common with the third term
plus delta il delta j k
all right now this particular
relationship
is uh what is describing the isotropic
material behavior
in addition to the to of course the
previous assumption
that is a linear behavior that it is not
accounting for any rate or history
effects and
because we are dealing with constants
here the assumption of uniformity or
homogeneity is very much embedded within
it
but very importantly we have now also
embedded within it
the information from isotropy okay now
usually
when in the context of elasticity we
don't use these
constants alpha and beta
rather we use two other constants it's
just a convention
that we use instead of alpha and beta we
use
lambda and g
now if we were to use this particular
relationship
in the material behavior
so c i j k l epsilon here
this relation sigma i j connected to the
epsilon k l
if we had to substitute this okay then
what happens
let's see that
this entire thing multiplied with
epsilon kl
so for the first term what we'll have is
uh this delta ij will remain as it is
now this kronecker delta uh it'll
act to substitute these indices so what
we'll have is
epsilon kk okay so you can think of it
like this l is getting substituted by
the scheme
delta ij plus
uh c
uh this k here
so this is going to get substituted by i
and this l
here this is going to get substituted by
this j
okay so what we'll have is epsilon
i a similarly here
we'll have so i'm just expanding it out
plus g uh
or we can put this within bracket no
problem send that thing within bracket
here this k is common here so
it's going to get replaced by
the j and this l is going to get
replaced by the i
so this is epsilon j i
but we know that epsilon ig is equal to
epsilon gi
as always so what we have
effectively is this thing
lambda epsilon kk delta ij plus
twice g epsilon i j and this is the
relationship
which we are looking for and this will
be utilized all throughout the rest of
this
course okay
now you please note that in your earlier
studies
when you refer to the generalized
hooke's law you expressed the various
components of the strains in terms of
the stresses
using the young's modulus and poisons
ratio and
what we have obtained here is basically
the stresses in terms of the strains
now please note that this is just
a different form of the generalized
hooke's law
okay just a different way of looking at
the generalized oops law that you
learned in your
undergraduate days okay and indeed in
your problem sheet you will be asked to
find out
the connections between these two things
okay specifically
what is the connection between lambda g
and that
young's modulus e and the poisson ratio
nu okay
so with this introduction
uh we have covered the theory part of
the material behavior chapter and
we can you can start doing the problems
now
all right with this we end this chapter
thank you very much